[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ih allen einen schönen guten
Abend Christin ist mit mir im Studio
hast jede Menge Fußball im Angebot
Männer und Frauen guten Abend dann
blicken wir gemeinsam auf die
Themen die Ampel macht Tempo der mühsam
errungene Sparhaushalt für 2024 soll
überraschend schon morgen dem Kabinett
vorgelegt werden
Krieg in der Ukraine und kein Frieden in
Sicht nach einem schwierigen Jahr zieht
Präsident selenski
Bilanz und heftiger Vulkanausbruch auf
Island nach wochenlangen Beben Spritzen
seit der Nacht Lavafontänen aus einer
Kilometer langen
Erdspalte ja damit war in diesem Jahr
nicht mehr unbedingt zu rechnen schon
morgen soll der mühsam erreichte und bis
gestern innerhalb der Ampel heftig
umstrittene Haushalt 2024 ins
Bundeskabinett und dort wie es heißt zur
Kenntnis genommen werden gekürzt werden
soll vor allem bei den internationalen
Ausgaben und fliegen wird wohl teurer
mehr von Patrizia
Wiedemeier die gestrigen Proteste der
Landwirte haben nicht geholfen genauso
wenig wie die des
Landwirtschaftsministers gegen die
Beschlüsse der eigenen
Regierung ich halte nichts von den
Streichungen in diesem Umfang und ich
habe auch früher nichts davon gehalten
im Gegenteil ich habe in der
Bundesregierung davor gewarnt
Agrardiesel und die KFZ Steuerregeln
abzuschaffen doch für die Landwirte hat
sich nichts geändert die Streichung von
agrardieselsubventionen und KFZ
Steuervergünstigungen ist im
Kabinettsentwurf unverändert enthalten
920 Millionen will die Regierung durch
die Kürzungen in der Landwirtschaft
sparen zudem werden Flüge teurer da die
Luftverkehrsabgabe steigen soll 800
weniger gibt es für internationales
Engagement 380 Millionen weniger für den
Verkehrsbereich und 600 Millionen
weniger für die Rentenkasse zusätzliche
Einnahmen von 1,4 Milliarden erhofft
sich die Ampel durch eine
plastikabgabe für die Opposition alles
nur trixserei die Ampel hätte genug
Einsparmöglichkeiten gehabt z.B beim
umstrittenen heizgesetz das heizgesetz
das unsinige das hätte man einfach
abschaffen können das spart Milliarden
da will man nicht dran stattdessen
greift man den Beitragszahlern und den
Steuerzahlern jetzt wieder tief in die
Tasche also wieder mal eine vertane
Chance trixen geht weiter morgen schon
schneller als erwartet soll der Haushalt
im Kabinett zur Kenntnis gegeben im
Januar dann im Bundestag beraten
werden ja dann gehen wir nach Berlin zu
Diana Zimmermann Diana die Ankündigung
überrascht ja doch womit ist jetzt zu
rechnen ja die überrascht tatsächlich
gestern hieß es explizit von der der
Bundesregierung dass der Haushalt morgen
nicht im Kabinett vorliegen werde nun
tut er es doch damit muss man damit
rechnen dass das ein Schluss ähm Zeichen
sein sollte für diese unselige
Diskussion die schon in der vergangenen
Woche wieder angefangen hat über den
Haushalt jetzt also ein Stoppzeichen aus
dem Kanzleramt dazu wir haben die Posten
gerade gesehen eine ziemlich
beträchtliche Sparliste das wird vielen
Bürgern weh tun und vielen Unternehmen
und es ist ganz klar dass es der Ampel
sehr schwer werden wird mit diesen
Sparmaßnahmen an Beliebtheit zuzulegen
die Opposition spricht davon dass es
sich weniger um Subvention Abbau als
viel mehr um Steuererhöhungen Handler
und spricht außerdem von
verschiebebahnhöfen weil sowohl die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit als auch die
Rentenversicherung belastet wird was ist
denn jetzt eigentlich mit den internen
ampelbedenken sind die jetzt vom Tisch
die sind nicht wirklich vom Tisch also
intern ist es ist jetzt festgelegt wo
gespart wird das sind die Eckpunkte aber
der Finanzminister wird in den kommenden
Tagen mit den einzelnen Ministerien
besprechen wie die Vorlagen für den
Bundestag aussehen also wie das
formuliert wird was jetzt eingespart
werden soll und davon gehe ich aus da
werden noch mal einige Differenzen
aufkommen und eventuell auch das Licht
der Öffentlichkeit erblicken der Plan
ist aber der dass Mitte Januar die
Bereinigungssitzung für den Haushalt
stattfinden soll dann geht
die Gesetzesvorlage in den Bundestag
dort soll sie Ende Januar beschlossen
werden und dann soll das Gesetz zum
Haushalt am 2 Februar durch den
Bundesrat gegangen sein das Kapitel wird
uns weiter beschäftigen danke schön
Diana Zimmermann nach Berlin und da
bleiben wir jetzt auch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat heute
entschieden dass die Bundestagswahl 2021
in Berlin teilweise nachgeholt werden
muss die Verantwortlichen die werden
sich nur ungerne zurückerinnern es war
ja eine absolute pannenwahl weil so
chaotisch sah es nämlich am Wahltag in
der Haupt Stadt aus Berlinerinnen und
Berliner mussten in langen Schlangen vor
Wahllokalen stehen die teilweise bis
weit nach 18 Uhr geöffnet waren
Stimmzettel waren falsch oder fehlten
ganz und jetzt soll am 11 februar in 455
von
2256 Wahlbezirken neu gewählt werden
genaueres von Sarah
Tacke so geht's nicht urteilten die
Richterin und Richter am
Bundesverfassungsgericht heute die
Wahlfehler die sie gefunden haben sind
so zahlreich und so gravierend dass die
Bundestagswahl in Teilen Berlins
wiederholt werden muss die Abläufe bei
der Bundestagswahl 2021 in Berlin weisen
Wahlfehler sowohl bei der Vorbereitung
als auch bei der Durchführung der Wahl
auf gravierende Pannen wurden aber nur
in etwas mehr als einem Fünftel der
Wahllokale festgestellt und nur dort
muss auch neu gewählt
werden die Richterin und Richter am
Bundesverfassungsgericht haben heute
deutlich gemacht nur dort wo die wefler
so gravierend waren dass sie sich auf
die Sitzverteilung im Bundestag
ausgewirkt haben könnten nur dort muss
Berlin neu wählen die teilneuwahl wird
keine Auswirkungen auf die Mehrheit im
Bundestag haben gerade für die
Linkspartei hätte eine umfangreichere
Wiederholungswahl zur Zitterpartie
werden
können wir sind erstmal erleichtert dass
es nicht zu einer komplett
Wiederholungswahl kommt sondern dass es
eine teilwiederholungswahl ist unsere
beiden direkt gewonnenen Wahlkreise sind
nicht in Gefahr somit wird auch die
Linke weiterhin im Deutschen Bundestag
vertreten sein die neuwahlnachricht
stößt in Berlin auf weniger Begeisterung
das mich ärgert ist dass es überhaupt
weit kommt dass wir Pann haben dadurch
dass Wahlen wiederholt werden müssen
dass Dinge so schlecht organisiert sind
ich denke glücklich ist es nicht aber
trotzdem finde ich es gut dass noch mal
neu gewählt wird ein Termin steht schon
fest die Wiederholungswahl soll am 11
februar
stattfinden im Tarifstreit mit der Bahn
da zeigt die GDL Muskeln mit 97% der
Stimmen sprachen sich die Mitglieder der
lokomotivführergewerkschaft in einer
Urabstimmung für unbefristete Streiks
aus bisher hatten die Reisenden schon
zweimal mit den Folgen eintägiger GDL
Warnstreiks zu kämpfen Gewerkschaft
fordert mehr Geld aber vor allem kürzere
Arbeitszeiten die Bahn lehnt dies ab wir
sprechen jetzt mit Peter Tyson der ist
in Wiesbaden am Hauptbahnhof mit müssen
den Bahnreisen jetzt
rechnen ja es könnten harte Zeiten
werden für alle Bahnreisenden im Januar
gdlchef weselski hat heute klar gemacht
dass es nicht bei eintägigen Streiks
bleiben werde vielleicht ein desjavue
mit 2021 als schon mal 5 Tage am Stück
fast kein Zug mehr in Deutschland fuhr
aber bis zum 7 Januar hält die GDL der
erstm noch die Füße still es ist also
vielleicht noch Zeit für ein kleines
Weihnachtswunder vielleicht kommen GDL
und Ben ja doch noch mal zusammen aber
es sieht dem nach es sieht derzeit nicht
danach aus die gd1 fordert ja 555 €
monatlich mehr plus ein
Inflationsausgleich für ihre
Beschäftigten Laufzeit ein Jahr die Bahn
bietet bisher 11 % mehr allerdings bei
32 Monaten Laufzeit entscheidend ist für
die GDL aber folgendes sie will auf
jeden Fall die 35 Stundenwoche bei
vollem Lohnausgleich ist angesichts der
Personalsituation überhaupt nicht mit
uns zu machen sagt die Bahn wir müssen
uns also auf einen ganz harten
Arbeitskampf im Januar einstellen und
mit viel Stillstand auf Deutschlands
Schienen vielen Dank für die Einordnung
Peter
Tyson die Kreuze in bayerischen Behörden
dürfen hängen bleiben so hat das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht entschieden die
Richter wiesen damit eine Klage des
religionskritischen Bundes für
Geistesfreiheit ab der sogenannte
kreuzerlass ist aus dem Jahr 2018
demnach müssen in allen staatlichen
Gebäuden in Bayern gut sichtbar Kreuze
angebracht sein das hatte die Landes
Regierung von CSU Ministerpräsident
Söder trotz heftiger Kritik
verfügt die Ukraine blickt auf ein sehr
schweres Jahr zurück die Hoffnungen dass
es gelingt die russischen Angreifer aus
einem Großteil der besetzten Gebiete zu
vertreiben haben sich nicht
erfüllt der Frontverlauf im Osten und
Süden der ist seit Monaten fast
unverändert kaum Raumgewinn Angriffe und
Gegenangriffe auf beiden Seiten fast
jede ukrainische Familie hat zu beklagen
Präsident selenski setzt bei seinem
Ausblick fürs nächste Jahr weiter auf
die Hilfe aus dem Westen Tim
Kröger das Interesse ist groß als
selenski zur Pressekonferenz erscheint
die Lage in der Ukraine ist derzeit
schwierig aber er zeigt sich
teilsoptimistisch dieser Winter ist
anders ja es gibt viele
Herausforderungen und
Verluste viele Verluste aber wir werden
jeden Monat stärker
wir hatten wichtige Besuche und werden
mehrere neue Patriot Luftabwehrsysteme
haben gerade erst war selenski viiel auf
Reisen er glaubt daran dass die USA und
die EU die Milliardenhilfen doch noch
freigeben außerdem geht es um die
weitere Mobilisierung von bis zu 500.000
Soldaten die die militärspitze
vorschlägt und natürlich die Situation
an der Front auf kievs Straßen herrscht
längst er nüchterung vielen fehlt eine
Perspektive in diesem Krieg offen gesagt
sehe ich keine Veränderungen es wird so
weitergehen wie in diesem Jahr es ist
eine harte Zeit für uns es ist hart für
jeden wegen des Krieges und ich weiß
nicht was als nächstes kommt Berichte
von erschöpften Soldaten und mangelnder
Munition holfen sich und ein Ende des
Krieges scheint nicht in Sicht wird der
Krieg
2024 zu Ende gehen ich denke keiner
kennt die Antwort selbstangesehene
westliche Militärs die sagen der Krieg
dauert noch Jahre wissen das noch
nicht auch 2024 wird ein schwieriges
Jahr für die Menschen in der
Ukraine und auch der gasakrieg stellt
die internationale Gemeinschaft vor
größte Herausforderungen aktuell machen
jemenitische hui Rebellen die sich mit
der Hamas solidarisch erklären eine der
wichtigsten Seerouten der Welt unsicher
sie führt durch den Kanal und das Rote
Meer die Rebellen haben zuletzt mehrere
Frachtschiffe mit Drohnen und Raketen
angegriffen und jetzt wollen die USA mit
einer staatenallianz für Schutz sorgen
Sandra
teis Einsatz im Roten Meer ein US
Kriegsschiff Wert Angriffe der hui
Rebellen ab das ist das Ziel der
maritimen Allianz die die USA jetzt ins
Leben gerufen haben Handelsschiffe zu
schützen die Rebellen zeigen sich auf Ex
ehemals Twitter unbeeindruckt er leren
selbst wenn es Amerika gelingt die ganze
Welt zu mobilisieren werden unsere
Militäreinsätze nicht aufhören es sei
denn die völkermordverbrechen in Gaza
werden
gestoppt seit Beginn des Gaza Krieges
greifen die hui Rebellen aus dem Jemen
verstärkt Frachtschiffe an hier filmten
sie sich selbst dabei die Lage im Roten
Meer ist hochgefährlich sagen Experten
was wirer erleben ist eine ganz andere
Qualität an Bedrohung als das in den
Jahren vorer der Fall war und das ist
auch etwas wo also zurecht jetzt
redereinen ihre Schiffe soweit es geht
eben aus der Risikozone rauslozen und
sich in auf alternative Routen
ausweichen an Stelle durch das Rote Meer
zu fahren wo die hui Rebellen aus dem
Jemen angreifen nehmen viele rädereien
jetzt die Route um die Südspitze Afrikas
die Folgen längere Lieferzeiten höhere
Kosten der Verband Deutscher Räder
fordert jetzt dass sich Deutschland an
der amerikanischen Militärallianz
beteiligt und stößt auf zurück tung wir
müssen ganz klar sehen dass diese
Allianz wichtig ist und notwendig ist
gleichzeitig hat die Bundeswehr auch
ganz klare
Restriktionen an welchen Mandaten Sie
sich beteiligen kann und da muss auch
müsste auch der Bundestag mit einbezogen
werden laut Bundesverteidigungsminister
Pistorius derzeit in Niger wird ein
Einsatz der Bundeswehr im Roten Meer
geprüft der is-attentäter von Duisburg
muss wegen Mordes und mehrfachen
Mordversuchs lebenslang ins Gefängnis
das Oberlandesgericht Düsseldorf
verurteilte ihn außerdem zu
anschließender
Sicherungsverwahrung der 27-Jährige Syr
hatte im April auf offener Straße einen
Mann mit zahlreichen Messerstichen
getötet ein paar Tage darauf stach er in
einem Fitnessstudio vier Männer nieder
und verletzte sie dabei
schwer jetzt nach China dort hat ein
Erdbeben mindestens 127 Menschen das
Leben gekostet über 500 verletzt wurden
bislang gemeldet es ist in der Nacht als
im Nordwesten Chinas in der Provinz
ganzu die Erde bebt mit einer Stärke von
6,0 so das deutsche
geoforsorschungszentrum viele werden
noch vermisst tausende sitzen bei
Minusgraden auf der Straße aus China
Elisabeth
Schmidt sie haben nicht nur das Beben
sondern auch eine klirrend kalte Nacht
überlebt die Provinz Gansu ist eine von
Chinas ärmsten Regionen viele Dörfer
liegen hier auf einer
nachts wird es zurzeit bis zu 20° kalt
als die Erde bebt ist es kurz vor
Mitternacht viele werden im Schlaf
überrascht die meisten Häuser in dem
ländlichen Gebiet sind sehr einfach
gebaut mit Ziegelsteinen und leben 155
000 von ihnen werden nach offiziellen
Angaben entweder beschädigt oder
komplett zerstört hunderte Menschen
unter den Trümmern begraben oder
eingeklemmt das Beben löst in der
bergigen Region auch mehrere lamlawinen
aus das Staatsfernsehen zeigt vor allem
Glücksmomente wie diesen eine
verschüttete wird lebend geborgen die
Behörden demonstrieren
Stärke unser Ziel ist das Leben zu
retten und den Betroffenen zu helfen
alle Behörden arbeiten zusammen um Essen
Trinkwasser eine Unterkunft und
medizinische Versorgung zu
gewährleisten allerdings größere
Kliniken liegen bis zu 100 km von der
Erdbeben Region entfernt noch suchen die
Rettungsteams weiter nach Vermissten
doch mit der nächsten klirrend kalten
Nacht wächst die Sorge dass die Zahl der
Opfer in ganszu weiter steigen
wird in Island da bebt die Erde ja schon
seit Wochen und jetzt ist ein Vulkan
ausgebrochen der liegt auf der Halbinsel
rekernis das ist nur 40 km südwestlich
der Hauptstadt rekierweg schon im
November mussten tausende ihre Häuser in
der Gemeinde grinderwieg verlassen
seitest gestern Abend sprudeln jetzt
Lavafontänen aus einer riesigen
Erdspalte zu CDI
berichtet die Erde speit Feuer
schleudert Lava und Asche 120 m in die
Luft die glühende Masse bahnt sich ihren
Weg auf 4 km Länge zieht sich die
glutspalte der erdriss auf der ranes
Halbinsel im Südwesten Islands Heimat
von Margret palzotier die sie bereits
vor 6 Wochen verlassen
musste eine Stunde vor dem Ausbruch dann
hat man gesehen dass dann kamen viel
viel mehr Erdbeben plötzlich wie
Sonnenaufgang dann ist der Vulkan
ausgebrochen
und es ist ein Ausbruch mit Ansage
unweit der isländischen Hauptstadt
regjawieg nördlich des kleinen Ortes
grinderwieg der wurde bereits im
November geräumt Touristenattraktionen
gesperrt die Behörden ernst aber
gelassen Island ist vor bereitet Island
kennt
das der Ausbruch ist heftiger als
erwartet aber die Lava fließt bisher
nicht in Richtung der Ortschaft sondern
in die Gegenrichtung nach Norden wenn
das so bleibt kommen wir glimpfleicht
davon jetzt heißt es für die Menschen
auf der Halbinsel abwarten momentan aber
besteht keine
Gefahr sieht trotzdem beeindruckt aus
wir sind jetzt beim Sport Christi
englische Woche in der Fußball
buundesliga und Dortmund steht ganz
schön m und die müssen auch noch ein
Trauma bewältigen national hingt der BVB
seinen eigenen Ansprüchen weit hinterher
als Tabellen fünfter mit 13 Punkten
Rückstand auf den ersten Leverkusen am
Abend das Duell mit Mainz also der
Mannschaft die Ende Mai Dortmunds
Meisterträume je platzen ließ es läuft
nicht alles nach Plan beim BVB zuletzt
erneut nur ein Unentschieden gegen
Augsburg dennoch sagt der Trainer der
Rückhalt sei
groß das kann ich nur bestätigen dass
ich diese Rückendeckung spürre sowohl
von den Mens die die mit mir
zusammenarbeiten als auch aus der Kabine
über dieses Titel Trauma vor knapp 7
Monaten will der Motivator tersit nicht
sprechen als man 2 Z2 gegen Main spielte
und damit die Meisterschaft verspielte
positive Gedanken bestimmen das Hier und
Jetzt drei Punkte sollen her gegen den
Tabellenvorletzten aus Mainz wir wissen
dass sie dass sie besser spielen können
als jetzt gerade aktuell in der Tabelle
da stehen wir aber auch bevor also so
etwas wie Weihnachtsstimmung aufkommt
beim BVB heißt es
Arbeiten genau das Stichwort hart
arbeiten will auch weiterhin Thomas
Müller beim FC Bayern München seit 2000
beim Rekordmeister unter Vertrag
verlängerte er diesen um ein weiteres
bis Juni
25 die Frauen des VfL Wolfsburg
überwintern als Bundesliga
spitzenreiterinnen am Tag nach dem
Patzer der Bayern Spielerinnen
übernahmen sie durch den Sieg gegen
Bremen die Tabellenführung
82 Minuten lang bissen sich die
Wolfsburgerinnen die Zähne an Bremen aus
vor allem kombianerin Katalina Peres 12
Torschüsse für Wolfsburg aber eine
Torhüterin der Extraklasse im Gegenzug
Bremen mit nur vier Torschüssen aber
auch Chancen wie diesem Pfostentreffer
doch dann sieht Katalina Perz
unglücklich aus diese irgendwie perfekt
verzogene Flanke von Dominik Jansen
trifft ins Tor und ins Bremer Herz zum
glücklichen 1:0 für Wolfsburg von daher
bin ich da sehr sehr stolz auch auf die
Mannschaft auch auf die Leistung das
heute noch mal ja wirklich in dre Punkte
umzumünzen die wolfsburgeren wieder an
der
Tabellenspitze und Ende Januar geht's
weiter vielen Dank Christin so weiße
Weihnachten wohl eher nicht erstmal viel
Regen ein Sturm und noch mehr Regen
Details gleich mit Katja horneffer das
heute journal mit dunia Haali das gibt's
ab
22:45 Uhr schön dass sie heute dabei
waren vielen Dank und machen Sie sich
noch einen entspannten
[Musik]
Abend
guten Abend von nordenzog heute Regen
heran und jetzt in der Nacht wird aus
diesem Regen jedenfalls erhalb von 600
bis 800 m durchaus auch mal ein bisschen
Schnee also in den Mittelgebirgen im
Wesentlichen wird das aber eine
regnerische Nacht und die Temperaturen
sinken auf 6° an der Nordsee und bis 0°
in Niederbayern in Süddeutschland reicht
also durchaus noch mal für Glätter die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei 3°
am Alpenrand und in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und 9° am niederrein die
Regen und schneeregenwolken ziehen
morgen im Laufe des Tages hier
südostwärts ab dann wird es im Südwesten
ganz freundlich bevor dann der nächste
Regen von Nordwesten herin kommmt und
zum späten Nachmittag können die Wolken
bei einem kräftigen Wind aus westlichen
Richtungen direkt an der Küste durchaus
schon mal aufreißen und dann wird es
stürmisch den Höhepunkt des Sturms
erwarten wir Donnerstag Donnerstagabend
in der Nacht auf Freitag und Freitag
über Tag und es kommt nicht nur viel
Wind mit sondern auch viel Regen und da
die Böden jetzt schon aufgeweicht sind
kommt dieser zusätzlich Regen noch dazu
viele Bäume werden also Umstürzen guten
Abend